[Music]
[Applause]
dude chill we're about to take out
literally the biggest criminals in town
yes and we are the biggest
crime-fighting duo look we just need to
close the deal okay we get in we give
the illegal merch and then we scream
[Music]
[Applause]
Brett it's me man
you got what we're looking for
it's that serious firepower good
[Music]
hey check it out man it's not gonna bite
you come on now this is a pink 9 mil 30
round mag now if you want to start a war
don't want this by your side it's hella
legal very so for my end of the deal
[Applause]
[ __ ] man for that much been had the
whole lot of that's alright man we just
need mom man my crews already locked and
loaded we're good hey nothin that will
take them yeah
so we have a deal I know you know my
hands are full though gotcha
[Music]
[Music]
come on ammo
[Music]
hands up you piece of trash
[Music]
it's over turn around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you killed my partner you son of a [ __ ]
or you're gonna kill me too you don't
have what it takes I got better things
in store for you
[Music]
great work boys
taking those fools out was no small feat
I knew I could count on the biggest cops
to handle the biggest crime thanks a lot
chief it means a lot to us yeah well you
know what you boys should take the day
off that's an order
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right it's supposed to be just a guy
getting shot in the head butter this
room for more creativity dueling pistols
[Music]
works best when the exhaust tube is
placed inside the underwear
[Music]